You may have noticed that the symmetric, so what happens on the left is
reversed on the right. In the first region, we see the graph starts off at the
horizontal asymptote y equals 0, and rises to the vertical asymptote of x
equals 3. We can also say it is increasing at the y-value of each point, as we
move right, is greater than the y-value of the point before. In the last
region, it's the opposite. It starts at the vertical asymptote and falls to the
horizontal one, this means it's decreasing. At x equals 3, we have an
asymptote. And the curve to the right of that rises from negative infinity up
to the maximum that you found in the question before at 3.5 comma negative 4,
before falling again towards negative infinity as it approaches the asymptote x
equals 4.